hogyha megfogunk egy eekvadorit áthozzuk
udvarhelyre és udvarhelyről megfogunk
egy udvarhelyt és átvisszük ecvadorra ba
és ottan másfél hónapot él az egyik és a
másik is elkerülhetetlen hogy
előbb-utóbb rutinná válik neki az a
környezet ahol van az a kérdés hogy ezen
a rutinon fölül van-e valami van-e
valami amit tud ajánlani udvarhely vagy
akkor ugye ebben az esetben ecador én
ezt keresem és tudom hogy udvarhely a
rutinon fölül tud adni nagyon sokat
tehát egy egy egy olyan vasárnapi séta
amikor amikor nem nagyon járnak az autók
mikor szépen süt a nap vagy mikor szépek
a felhők az egy hatalmas felüdelés ebben
a városban